hi Bruce tell me about your time playing
the division this week I hear it I hear
it's a real glitch festival feel gross
really you played it some friends you
had a good time I still feel gross it's
like one of those things were like you
know what you're doing is just a
complete waste of time you can rise I'm
Way better with your time but you just
stick it out and ya doing this nice
weather on the weekend is always
beautiful yeah I actually made myself go
outside twice cuz it was just like this
is dumb so we do so it explains me what
you're doing you're playing the division
with some of your buddies I here I heard
from Erin who is the planes division
basically non stop since it came out
yeah what about what you guys gonna
happen on and off I hear this a bunch of
sort of exploits going on there but it
seemed like that stuff really cranked
into high gear yeah well I mean it's
been going on at least about the entire
duration I've been playing the game and
I think I started playing a lot on
Thursday maybe wednesday of last week
pretty aggressively you know multiple
like you know two to three hours a night
and then on the weekends man I'm just
playing it all day but I was playing
with some guys and it's just crew I run
with and they're always like geared out
to the max and and did you also play
with them in the crew know another
property you saw title proof no okay no
I never even didn't go across no you did
not so [ __ ] lot you know you did with
me and I'm bill I mean that was the only
time I played it when he tried to go to
San Francisco yeah visit our hometown
whose great only go to e3 we did we
finished that the county system anyway
sorry sorry the division um yeah anyways
so I play with these guys they're both
geared all a good crew of people and
essentially they showed me a bunch of
exploits like what people have been
doing I guess for the last two weeks
three weeks are maybe since the games
come out I have no idea but it was it
was bizarre stuff we're like it the the
incursion just came outside when the
deal say they've released and I had
never beaten the incursion on
challenging okay what you're seeing
right now is the actual glitch itself so
um but the idea is you go down this
ladder you go through this tunnel when
you did basically you can just skip
everything you have to worry about in
terms of like these 15 waves of enemies
coming and then using some weird like
cover glitch where you go from one cover
to the next you can climb up basically
through the world yeah into this
nebulous
the room like maybe a part of the game
that the massive will expand upon and ya
later DLC yeah there's a hobo they're
out there they gave some new so yeah one
model if you give her a bottle water
she'll give you like an article of
clothing or a gun it is like a city
environment anyways you go around and
then you can actually see this weird
grey wall you can actually see where
you're supposed to be you see the APC
and you can just go up there and just
start firing sticky bombs which usually
has like waves of stuff around yeah so
once you initiate that you get like 15
waves of enemies that I think the
incursion itself on challenging again
I've never successfully done it on
challenging it I know it can take people
up to an hour if not more right yeah
that's probably longer if your groups
not that strong because there's like way
higher level enemies and whatnot is just
that like last week's glitch was already
kind of bad but this one that thi showed
me I just like this is pretty ridiculous
that's why you're climbing a fake ladder
through the world yeah and then on top
of that you're shooting the APC through
like an invisible wall so to speak and
noah and the npcs can get you sometimes
so you just said this week's glitch so
it's like like damn it like DLC drops
was lots of last week's glitch you could
just use the the barricade type thing or
if you had two people could kind of
shield glitch each other through a wall
in the incursion right and the way that
worked was like okay as long as you
don't go through the main window none of
the enemies see you or like do anything
to you as long as you don't go to a
certain area yeah and you're just
standing right next to the APC and you
just sticky mod it till it dies yeah but
this week's new exploit which I have no
idea how people figure this out they
must be like testers or something I
again the crew I was with me I don't
know where they learn they heard of
major showed me part of them a girl who
hurt my god by the way there's also
multiple ways to do that exactly which
it's currently I don't even think it's
fixed as of today but there's multiple
ways to do it they just showed me this
way through the world you walk up this
invisible ladder then you start firing
your sticky bomb at it but I will say
this with the group of four and yeah
they're all decked out with high skill
power you can take that thing down in
like 30 minutes and you can still get
around to pick up your drop afterwards
but yeah so what happens is especially
if it's a weekly challenge you get like
you get your reward
immediately which is like a level 240
piece of gear and then you can actually
fast travel to the beginning of the
mission right go down the sewer like you
were going to normally do go all the way
it's like empty empty because it's like
oh you beat it you're done in your drop
is still there so I saw one earlier
today as well that had somebody
glitching into a wall in the dark zone
that was the safe zone glitch now okay
apparently you can you can again the
same wallhack method that Eric was
talking about yeah and the first this is
just a deployable cover thing there's
just loads of like yeah we're next
lights happening with that thing yeah I
mean that's what people are using now to
just go through any wall essentially at
this point and I believe there's even
more glitches where you can get into the
like get into that weird again Blue Room
yeah white room level area we can like
shoot through walls but that's what this
person is doing in this one where they
can go into the safe house without
actually entering it using that let
mobile cover glitch and then they can
shoot players as they're trying to enter
the safe zone like you know this
particular safe zone 2 has a vendor that
sells high-end gear so people are going
there to like either restock on amo or
gear they can get shot and killed though
at that point the guy that's doing the
glitch can level up his rank and the
dark zone I don't know how fast or
effective it would be but essentially
they're just going rogue and then
outlasting their rogue timer or manhunt
timer alright let's step back away from
this for a second because like obviously
can we can chat and say oh my god this
guy's broke above like glitches are part
and parcel of a lot of online games and
you fell out destiny does this like
there were exploits within a lot of the
yeah like for the glass and stuff there
was like waysm you can like skip through
parts and one like to be honest like I
think about like why rating I was almost
part of the challenge was I know finding
out like the the best tactic and like
itching you know going through walls is
one thing maybe but like you know being
able to like skip certain parts of
molten core was always like good sort of
a good thing does this seem more
egregious in the division it's only more
egregious because of how the system or
how the game works so right now
incursion which is the thing that's
getting exploited the most is offering
players the highest tier of loot that
you can get in the game and it's I think
it's like currently the only place you
can get it so of course people are going
to exploit it right because it's like
not only is it so much faster than doing
it normally but it's really the only
you can get it at ya so in a way it's
it's kind of almost like there's
something wrong with the design of the
game potentially only because like it's
such a loot driven game and this exploit
is basically really harming the game
because you have your demographic that
you know like the hardcore or whoever
that are you know exporting all the time
and then you have your casual players or
your people that have high ethics and
they don't want to exploit and then
they're like well like massive should
punish these people and like the
community manager I think a massive is
even come outside like they're looking
into punishing people but it's like
weird because you can't really do that
because it's in the game right it's in
your game you have to fix your game well
it's like the difference between like
you know Rach critters in street fighter
5 and then people who are basically
taking yeah yeah but you know exposing
the holes in your product this is what's
happening here this is people in my
opinion at least talking to the people i
play with I asked them why they did it
you know and like it's like leveling the
playing field why so of you to do know
it's an interesting question to pose to
somebody because I don't have all day to
play this game you know and I'm a casual
player you know like these people are
playing hours and hours a day but the
main response I got to that was this is
the only way I can even catch up and and
at least somewhat compete in the dark
zone when people are out there with
super high-end rider and there's like
they have like really high armor
capacity they can basically take a ton
of damage and when they're in the dark
zone just wrecking shop going rogue and
annihilating people if you wanna if you
want to catch up if you want to compete
and you don't want to die immediately
you kind of have to do it so you know
it's like it's like the Tour de France
and cycling you know it's like
everyone's doping so I'm gonna [ __ ]
dope you know because I want to compete
you know and if everyone's doing it then
you have to do it although you're the
Lance Armstrong of exactly with one
testicle it's it's just it is annoying
though like and I and I grant like
granite I agree with Arik like half they
have to fix this there's a problem but
it also speaks more to their design of
the dark zone because like Elise in
destiny when you play multiplayer
everyone's kind of like on the same
level more that's it's like teamed at
myspace it's like skill right whereas
it's cool that the division has like
this unique dynamic we're like you know
you can go in there and wreck shop but
like if you have people that are getting
all this monster gear yeah and they
can't be killed easily and there
naya leaving everybody then it's like
what happens to the dark zone at that
point I mean the docks amazon I mean the
dachshund always seem like justice not
like an afterthought but almost like
they had that grand scope idea when they
wanted the division to be the sort of
like immersive always connected online
game would like these you know you can
pile up with people that you might run
into other people which was not the game
they ended up launching and if she
always felt like dark zone was just as
kind of like remnant like this leftover
parsh yeah that's sort of like stuck to
the rest of the game so I I think what's
interesting about this is when when I I
used to be in game dev briefly for like
18 months and I remember like when the
game launched that we were working on
devs can blow that go by look out yeah I
don't even know if it's for sale don't
worry unavailable but uh I know that
there's a there's a temptation for
deficit is react to everything really
quickly write about like feedback from
the community yeah like they'll they'll
just kind of especially if it's like a
you know smaller dev rice fund um if you
go there edit on division that's insane
right it's a lot of people complaining
and some of its rightfully so so if it's
just kind of like you know hey like this
is the state of the game calm down but I
think there is this tendency for divest
to react really quickly to things and I
think that's kind of what massive is
doing sometimes because like there are
times where I thought maybe they thought
that game was too easy so they made it
super hard drives people and then after
the beta it up Poppins yeah okay and
then even after this latest patch like
you know I remember playing a game one
like me I'm like a lot more I'm like a
piece of glass now it's like you know
one bullet I'm dead like these guys are
shotgunning me like these are just in
pcs like you regular people so you're
saying that like they're like papering
the cracks but in doing so sex somewhere
else it's not it's possible yeah i know
i'm not saying that's exactly what
they're doing but i know that they're
quick to react and i know that the game
has definitely changed and like up and
down kind of all over the place since i
started playing it so i'm a little
concerned that maybe they're being too
reactive i don't know i mean it's just
again like I have to imagine massive has
a pretty big squad and there and there
and this is by the way this is like a
completely different game that I worked
on so it is it's like no not even the
same but it's just it's interesting to
see how they're trying to fix everything
I mean this is this is going to be a
very hard time for them like just in
terms of like now and what they've had
and like up like what they have coming
because they're at a point where their
fan base is starting to kind of get
you know more critical more upset and
they might lose playerbase right and
they got to figure it out like destiny
it took them a year for them to finally
kind of get it like good like figure out
quality of life stuff and whatnot like
I'm afraid like I stopped playing the
division ready but part of that's
because I don't have a crew that I run
with normally but like even then it's
like your men maxing so hard on these
like pieces of gear and that's why
people are exploiting it's because like
for you to get the best gear it kind of
takes exploiting to get it because like
to do it normally you just gotta get
super lucky and it would take like
forever to be honest and I don't think
they found that balance yet of like what
is good they keep experimenting and
sometimes it's almost like they have too
many knee-jerk reactions but one of the
core gameplay was more fun that wouldn't
be a problem this wasn't just some like
yeah I mean I don't log of a sheer like
it's fun yeah it's a fine game but like
what we're talking about is that they're
like variable ratio schedule is just
don't work good enough where they're not
like rubbing your belt on our tongue
rubbing your back enough to get you
through what is basically a slog if
you're to play it over and over and over
again now you don't mean like yeah I
people play wild group raids and likes
like for better or worse it took six
hours of our evenings and did it like
that five days a week the people don't
do it on these games because the
gameplay is not there right because
that's not the type of game well its way
that's one same like before this recent
patch I actually enjoyed the gameplay
like I mean a granite I had a pretty
good squad I was teaming up with day in
and day out every night you don't have
to work and on the weekends it was a lot
of fun and I thought the gameplay was
like we were just running it was weird
cuz we were running the same missions a
lot you know like these weekly
challenges and like everything when
challenging mode it was super fun to do
but I never felt like it was really
really boring and then this patch
happened and the incursion happened and
then all of a sudden was like well this
game got like insanely it to me at least
it got more difficult yeah and then it
was like okay like eric said the only
way to get this good gear is to do this
at least in an optimal time is to
exploit you know and everyone's doing it
so like what do you do in that situation
do you just follow the same path or do
you try to do it if they do if somebody
else jumps off a bridge do you jump off
a bridge ty what's down there that's
awesome sick loot at I rude okay thank
you so much for coming on talking the
division of course I mean the fact that
we're still talking about
that's always been out for two months
yes there's one thing and you know
related so can't be all that bad let us
know what you think of the division and
its glitch festival that's going on
right now in the comments below